today on the matt welsh show the dnc
convention kicks off with a call to
unite america but what does unity look
like in the mind of a democrat
apparently it includes rioting and
looting and destruction so
we'll talk about all that also five
headlines including a college professor
who's
finally uncovered the sinister nature of
coloring books so you need to hear about
this and finally in our daily
cancellation we'll talk about the
the hate crime claim made weeks ago that
got a lot of attention at the time
but hasn't been mentioned by the media
or law enforcement since
i wonder why so all of that is on the
way but we start here the democratic
convention as mentioned kicks off
tonight
uh as you can imagine i'm very excited
there are really only a few things i'd
rather do than watch the dnc convention
for example
um stick my face in a blender i'd rather
do that but uh my blender isn't working
right now so that's good news for
my face i guess anyway i i really i took
note of the theme of the convention
um which is this if you can believe it
the theme is
uniting america now
as i've argued extensively in recent
months uniting
unity is nothing more than an empty
slogan
if it is advocated without context you
want unity okay
great but what do you mean who is you
uniting and around what and why and to
what end
um that's certainly the question you
would ask if some weirdo on the street
came up to you and said hey friend let's
unite
you'd hear that you'd say uh what do you
mean by unite
is that some sort of sexual euphemism uh
you need more information before you
agree to it is the point
so when i hear democrats call for unity
i have the same question i'm pretty sure
they don't mean it sexually though you
never know with these people but
what do they mean um and and and that
question takes on new urgency when you
consider for example
the words of the squads ringo uh ayanna
presley being interviewed on msnbc this
weekend
here's what she had to say listen to
this i'm looking to the public
you know this is as much about public
outcry
and organizing and mobilizing and
applying pressure
so that this gop led senate and that
these governors that continue to carry
water for this administration
putting the american peoples in harm's
way um
turning a deaf ear to the needs of our
families and our communities
hold them accountable well make the
phone calls send the email
show up you know there needs to be
unrest in the streets for as long as
there's unrest in our lives
and unfortunately there's plenty to go
around she wants
more unrest in the streets she's not
satisfied yet presley sitting on her
comfortable perch far away from the
burned-out neighborhoods the boarded-up
stores the looting the rioting the
assaults the murder the children in
cancer treatment centers laying in their
beds in terror as they listen to the
gunshots
as we talked about last week pressly
insulated from all of that insulated
from the chaos
and death and destruction wants more of
it wants it to continue
that's her unity and she's not alone in
democrat party not at all in fact her
view is mainstream is more than
mainstream is
the only acceptable or only accepted
view in fact
another example a few days ago blm
activists stormed a suburban
neighborhood in seattle
and demanded that white people give up
their homes
listen to
black people that their home thank you
we're sitting there comfortably
comfortable by that neighborhood i used
to live in this neighborhood
i used to live in this neighborhood and
my family was
because the majority of people that live
in the central district now work for
amazon because it's an easier commute to
downtown for
well guess what the guy you work for is
part of the
problem too so
let's not act like you just are
oblivious to this
because you knew about it all along and
you were okay with it
but guess what we're not and we're
bringing to your front door
what the [ __ ] are you planning to do
about it the windows calling the clouds
and now we're turning the lights off
because we called you a center
[Music]
you notice how having a good job is
literally a joke to these people
you guys have jobs at amazon where you
support your families
losers but what you have here really is
a gang of overgrown children a gang of
clowns
and losers demanding that they simply be
given what other people have worked for
now alexandria quezo cortez was recently
asked about
asked about this uh this this incident
by reporters asked if she condemns
what these blm children are doing and
here's what she said this is the quote
since this is happening in seattle i
don't have as close of a view on what's
happening of course i represent new
york's 14th congressional district so i
don't know the details of the protests
that are going on
but i think what's really important is
that we make sure people are safe and
it's important for us to enact
legislation and policy that actually
addresses the core reason behind all
of this kind of disruption that's
happening and then she added
until we do that this is going to keep
occurring whether we want it to or not
whether we want it to or not well
she wants it to that much is clear um
now let's let's look at some other
examples of this
unrest in the street that the democrat
that the democrat party explicitly
endorses and encourages
this is from last night in portland the
blm mob
caused a man to crash his truck then
knocked him unconscious and
left him bleeding in the street so
that's that's what happened let's
let's back up a little bit and see how
this all began i'm going to play that
video for you um
you'll see the mob swarm a truck the
truck drives away
and in the chaos ends up crashing so
we'll watch that part first watch
back up
back up back up back up
[Applause]
okay so so you see that and then they go
to the car
the guy gets out or is dragged out and
i'm not sure which one at which point
he's he's held hostage by the people by
these people detained
is the word i've seen used in the media
they detained him as if they're police
officers
and then they did this
what you mean you're not trying to hurt
no money
because you're talking about your life
[Music]
are you talking
yes
and after all of that of course they
robbed his truck because uh why not all
in the name of justice
okay just so you know and because of you
know george floyd or whatever
now again the democrat party explicitly
supports this it's not just that they
won't condemn it which they won't of
course but
that they as you heard from ringo they
positively advocate for it
so we go back to our original question
what do they mean by unity
they want to unite america well how so
unite us all in our shared affection for
beating white men unconscious is that
the idea
well sort of yeah for democrats when
they say unite
if you do not share their ideology and
affirm it absolutely
and especially if you're not an approved
if you're not in an approved
victim group then they're not looking to
unite with you but rather to unite
around a shared hatred
of you for the left and democrats the
uniting principle is one of vengeance
and hatred
and it's vengeance against and hatred of
you
that is their unity why do you think
they won't stand for the anthem because
it's too inclusive
oh say does that star-spangled banner
yet wave over the land of the free the
home of the brave
that's far too unifying it includes too
many people
that's their beef with it when it comes
down to it so a unity convention for
democrats is like a dinner party for
cannibals
they may invite you to the table but
it's only because you're on the menu
unity for them is highly specific highly
exclusionary
and anyone who doesn't pass the litmus
test is
an other a villain and they are
deserving of any fate that befalls them
including being knocked unconscious in
the street
that is the democrat party that is what
it stands for
that's the vision it has for this
country and we have
seen the vision increasingly realized
recently voters now just have to decide
if
they want more of that
now let's get to our five headlines
well the show today is uh supported by
rad power bikes
you know getting getting out and about
is that something especially when the
weather is nice like this that you want
to be able to do
um and uh you know maybe start to start
cooling down a little bit we get into
the fall
great time to be out and about well
that's what you need an electric bike
for
uh whether you know you want a new way
to get around town or out in nature
even with the kids in tow whatever it is
you've got to try rad power bikes just
give it a try and you'll be you'll be
hooked trust me it's a cross between a
traditional bike and a moped
but it doesn't require a special
driver's license or anything like that
you can go up to 20 miles per hour
without pedaling
so you can get out and about without
getting all sweaty and so that means
they're great for you know commuting to
work so you're not showing up at work
sweaty and disgusting i think your your
co-workers were
will appreciate that or you can haul
groceries like i said you can even have
kids on the back
unlike other e-bikes they're actually
affordable plus to show appreciation for
those that service rad power bikes is
offering 100
off all e-bike purchases for active um
ex-military first responders teachers
and students dedicated us-based customer
support seven days a week to any
uh to answer any questions that you
might have so they're there for you
this um product is i mean what i like
about it is that it's
it's a lot of fun but it's also really
practical it's something that you can
use
and have fun while you use it rad
powerbikes offers flexible financing for
as low as zero percent apr and right now
as a limited time offer get a free
accessory with the purchase of a bike
that's right get a free gift
of up to 100 in value and free shipping
to the lower 48 states
to get this special offer text the word
bike to 64
000 that's bike to 64 000 text bike to
64 000. all right number one let me
start with this
um first of all
can i just say at the outset that i i i
love controversies as much as the next
guy
more than the next guy probably i live
for it
it's great people fighting disagreeing
getting all offended about stuff
i'm into it i really am but every once
in a while
a controversy pops up that i just can't
get into i can't bring myself to care
and
we are in one of those news cycles right
now and it's really killing me
this postal service stuff there's a lot
of controversy surrounding the postal
service and mail-in voting
i i i can't even continue talking about
it right now because i might fall asleep
in the middle of speaking that's how
boring it is to me
i've tried working myself up about it i
really have i've i've practiced it i was
in the more
the mirror this morning practicing like
getting angry ah this
the postal service i'm so angry
and i couldn't i just couldn't do it i
tried so um
here i am left out while people care
about this for 37 seconds
but it's a torturous 37 seconds because
i feel so excluded
but all of that said i did appreciate
this at least this was um
the the closest i could come to being
interested which is right here
uh you can see the footage a protest at
the postmaster general's house
these are people who are concerned that
their ability to vote by mail
is being blocked by trump and the
general i don't know if he's a real
general but uh
anyway that's what i call him but the
funny thing of
of course is that they want to do
mail-in voting
because they don't want to have to go
out in public and vote because they're
afraid of the virus
yet they're out in public in a large
group protesting
that they might have to be out in public
in a much smaller group to vote so it's
just
it's it's this is really this is part of
the scientific
discovery process that's been very
interesting
uh really really fascinating frankly to
learn more and more about this virus
each
day because at first we thought you know
it's a virus
uh it can infect anyone really you know
certain demographics are not as
susceptible of course like children
but you know you figure like it's it's
sort of it's just a virus you know that
and that's what you think but then then
we learned that it really only infects
you
at church at school uh
or during anti-lockdown protests or
while voting in person but it doesn't
infect you
at walmart at target at blm protests
or while protesting voting in person
so like i said fascinating stuff and
this is why i just love science
i love learning things like this it
really is just
a lot of fun number two here's a better
controversy this is more my speed father
james martin
jesuit of course is going to be speaking
at the dnc
i think on thursday martin despite being
a catholic priest is known for his
far-left activism and in fact
as a catholic it pains me to say that we
might be reaching a point where i don't
need to say
despite anymore in that sentence but
anyway um
this is the guy for example who sent out
a tweet
after george floyd died asking for
george floyd to intercede for us in
heaven
he literally tried to canonize george
floyd via tweet
he's also a big lgbt activist big into
leftist causes in general so
on one level it makes sense for him to
speak at the dnc but on another level
he's allegedly a catholic and allegedly
a priest
and you can't really be either of those
in good standing
and have anything to do with the modern
democrat party the modern democrat party
is
expressly opposed to catholic teaching
christian teaching biblical teaching
and there are of course many examples of
this but we don't need to go any further
than the democrat party's
stated official position that children
in the womb
at any stage and for any reason
can be executed so martin should be
defrocked and excommunicated for this he
won't be
of course but uh he should be number
three a few weeks ago
i had to cancel ryan reynolds because
he issued a public apology for getting
married
at a wedding venue um that uh
you know you almost we might be reaching
a point where i could just stop the
sentence there
where you're gonna have celebrities
apologizing
uh at least heterosexual celebrities
apologizing for getting married
in general i i we we might we might be
reaching that point but we're not there
yet so he got
he he apologized for for getting married
at a wedding venue
that used to be a slave plantation 150
years ago he apologized for that
for some reason because apparently now
you know
you you can't uh even if a place is a
very pretty venue and there's a lot of
great scenery
if bad stuff happened there a century
and a half ago
you're not allowed to get married there
um so you know before you
get married anywhere or really go do
anything anywhere like go for a picnic
anything
you need to research do wikipedia go to
google maybe do an archaeological dig
to see what happened and then you can
have your picnic
but now reynolds is begging to be
canceled again really the premier of
british columbia for some reason
held a press conference begging ryan
reynolds and seth rogen to help him
fight the coronavirus
because of course in a medical crisis
the people you want to call
are the guy from deadpool and the guy
from knocked up
here's here's the premiere i've been
talking about the importance of making
sure that
younger demographics are hearing the
message this is a
call out to deadpool right now uh ryan
we need your help up here uh get in
touch with us
my numbers uh on the internet uh seth
rogen another outstanding british
columbian
we need to communicate with people who
aren't hearing us the two of you alone
could help us in that regard there's a
host of other options available and
we're working as hard as we can
to enlist a number of prominent british
columbians and prominent canadians
to help get that message through to the
demographic that clearly isn't hearing
our message
now reynolds in true cringe fashion
responded with for some reason a fake
voicemail
uh and this is what that sounded like
oh uh hey uh premier horgan ryan
reynolds here uh
i got your message about the thing
uh i'm not sure it's a great idea
frankly uh people don't i don't think
they want medical advice from guys like
me
no sir um unless it's plastic surgery
which a lot of people don't know this
but i used to be hugh jackman
uh you know in young folks in bc yeah
they're they're
partying um which is of course dangerous
uh and they probably don't know that
that thousands of
young people aren't just getting sick
from coronavirus that they're they're
also dying from it too
and of course it's the terrible that it
affects our most vulnerable
you know bc is that's home to some of
the coolest older people on earth i mean
david suzuki
did he lives there my mom
she doesn't want to be cooped up in her
apartment all day she wants to be out
there
cruising kitsilano beach looking for
some young 30-something
abercrombie burnout to go full mrs
robinson on
she is insatiable but here's the thing
um i hope that young people in bc don't
kill my mom
frankly uh or david suzuki or each other
let's not let's not kill anyone i think
that's reasonable
uh and you know but i just i i don't
think that i'm the guy to deliver this
message i love
parties my favorite thing to do is just
you know sit alone in my room with a
glass of gin in the first 32 seasons of
gossip girl
that's a party threw my shoulder out the
last time i did that
no one is going to kill your mother ryan
you paranoid lunatic
how people are partying okay um
if your mom's not going to those parties
then she should be all right
uh you know if she's going out and if
you know if she's practicing social
distancing wearing the mask
you know it's it's i i don't think
they're gonna
kill your mom i think i think it should
be really okay
uh especially if she's out on the beach
um
out in the you know open air keeping a
distance
i think everything will be fine um
number four
here's a a report from the new york post
it says uh twitter is
raging over a supposed call to cancel
genghis khan
all prompted by a woman who had merely
pointed out that the fearless 12th
century mongol
conqueror had also killed an awful lot
of people this is tweeted from user
priya27 said genghis khan did to central
asia what islamic invaders did to india
maybe worse he single-handedly killed 11
of the world population at the time yet
some want to glorify him as a hero and
conqueror that's your personal choice
but objectively genghis khan was a
barbarian
i saw these tweets now this is this was
tweeted out uh i thought
some interesting facts and points that
were made uh that
the 11 of the world population figure
i'd have to you know that's
that seems rather incredible i'd have to
go check that one myself but
anyway that's uh he certainly killed a
lot of people we know that and uh and
then people were mocking this though as
if she was trying to cancel genghis khan
posthumously
um i don't think that was the point at
all you know i i i think actually at
least one thing you could take from this
is that it turns out in fact that
white people did not invent wars of
conquest did not invent genocide
did not invent slavery all that stuff
has been happening in the world
has been happening in the world for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years this is just one example i don't
know if that was her point
but that is that is one historical
fact that you can take from this and to
put things in context and i think
especially these days
that is some useful context to have then
finally um
let's see here this is a report in the
daily wire i actually haven't read
through this yet i'm just grabbing it
based on the headline so
let's dive in it says in a piece
originally titled
there's a sinister reason coloring books
are so popular in quarantine a professor
who teaches the history of
the history of art ideas and technology
at stanford university and also writes
for the guardian in vogue
posits a unique take what if the recent
popularity of coloring books comes not
from the
creativity they purportedly inspire but
from the submission they induce
in the in the piece later we titled the
dark forgotten history of coloring books
emanuel lugely asserts this after all
has been their mission from the start
it may be lost to the fans of coloring
books that their success peaked in the
19th century
when such publications taught children
how to behave and obedience seems to be
what many of us crave in these pandemic
days
um noting yeah of course that it may be
lost to the fans of color
well the fans of coloring books for the
most part are seven years old so yes i'm
sure this is lost on them
i mean my seven-year-old has never asked
me about the history of coloring books
i'd be a little freaked out if she did
noting that the the little folks
painting book often described as the
first coloring book which depicts in its
last story a brother and sister who
wished to fly away from their boring
secluded life
um lugley asks uh does this semma
sum up what coloring books are about
stay within the lines
and then all right it goes on so okay
this is this is as crazy as i hoped it
would be so i'm
i'm encouraged by that
uh and i like where it's going my only
concern is that it doesn't go quite far
enough
yes coloring books teach submission um
so there's that but what about i mean
they also teach
a form of blackface and cultural
appropriation because think about it
you're taking these white characters
usually and coloring them much like
ralph northam you you're taking these
pasty white uh figures and putting
artificial color on them so i think that
this encourages
children to perform blackface not only
that but
coloring books are transphobic
because for for some reason
that i'm i'm be oh because they they
trivialize
body dysmorphia
by allowing you to change the physical
characteristics of the characters in the
coloring book so easily
thereby cheapening the lived experience
of dysmorphic individuals got it
okay so you can add on to this this so
i'm a little bit disappointed by this
professor
yeah you found one offensive aspect of
coloring books but what about everything
else
so you got to go you you really got to
go for the gusto on these things
um all right let's get to our daily
cancellation but
before we do i want to tell you about
our friends at eero
um you know it can be it can be kind of
frustrating
if there's that and i've got more than
one spot in my house
to be honest before i started using euro
where you get maybe one or two spots in
house
where the wi-fi really doesn't work that
well or you might have the one spot
where it works the best
and so you have to be huddled in that
corner using your your uh your laptop or
whatever
these days your house isn't just your
home it's an office it's a school it's a
movie theater it's a restaurant
everything all at once all these
activities and more put a strain on your
wi-fi
it's not good enough um if it's only
good in a room or two you want it to
reach the entire house you need solid
wi-fi in your whole house
so everyone isn't working on top of each
other that's why you need eero
hero an amazon company covers your your
whole home with fast
reliable wi-fi inside and out rooms with
bad to no wi-fi
if you have dropouts on your patio you
want to go outside and use the computer
eero makes every square foot of your
house and your property
usable by eliminating poor coverage and
dead spots
you'll have a consistently strong signal
where wherever you need it
it's that simple um i've been using it
myself
and uh and you know i've i've found
especially where we kind of live out
you know um in in an area where a lot of
people have
to struggle with the wi-fi connection
but ever since i've used euro you know
it's fast i can use it anywhere i go out
on the porch
during a nice day and use the computer
and i've got that the wi-fi
working we're asking a lot of our wi-fi
ero can help yours do more go to ero.com
walsh and enter codewall should check
out to get free next day shipping with
your order that's e-e-r-o
dot com slash walsh codewalsh at
checkout to get your eero delivered
with free next day shipping eero.com
walsh codewalsh
well this is another one of those
cancellations that i wish i didn't have
to do
this is the case for all of my
cancellations in fact to everyone that
i've cancelled
you should know that it hurts me more
than it hurts you i am
at heart a truly compassionate and
tolerant man
so it grieves me when you are so lame
and stupid that i have to cancel you
deeply deeply grieves me and never has
that been truer than right now today i
must
cancel um the police department of
madison wisconsin
i am a supporter of the police i i hate
the defund the police movement
i've spent a lot of time especially
recently defending the police against
unfair attacks
but the madison police must be canceled
even so and i'll explain why um
it stems from a case that i've been
following on the show even if nobody
else really has i follow because
i am of the increasingly unique and
perhaps bizarre
opinion that the truth matters and in
this day and age when lies and
misinformation and propaganda and false
narratives are helping to fuel the rapid
destruction of our society
the truth has never mattered more i
would say so
let's review briefly uh the case is that
of althea bernstein
18 year old madison wisconsin resident
seven weeks ago on june 24th althea
bernstein claims
she was driving through the city at 1am
stopped at a red light
she thinks around west gorham and state
street in in madison
and she says that at that moment four
white men
approached her vehicle two were wearing
floral shirts and jeans the other two
were dressed in all black and wearing
masks somehow she knew those two were
white also i don't know how but that's
not the point right now
she says they yelled a racial slurter
then
squirted some lighter fluid on her and
then threw a lighter into the car which
set her face on fire
and she says that she then drove away in
shock
eventually made it home went to the
hospital called the police the next day
now the media went wild with this story
at first it made headlines and all the
major publications it was used to
support the claim of a hate crime
epidemic in america
meghan markle uh called out the and
spoke with her for 40 minutes consoling
and offering advice because of course
megan
has had to deal with hate crimes herself
like the time that the maid left streaks
on the window after washing it
so she suffered quite a bit in her life
the point is and
and this was a pretty big deal at the
time and and of course it would be if it
happened
four flame throwing racist thugs
wandering the street of madison with
lighter fluid literally literally
setting black women on fire
that's a huge deal i mean it's it's it's
almost
unbelievable you might say of course
there were always some weird aspects of
this story such as
like every aspect of the story it was
the middle of the night
she's at a stoplight these guys show up
with lighter fluid what were they doing
just hanging out in the street waiting
for a racial minority to stop
they doused her with lighter fluid and
then and then the lighter and then and
then she drove away
why didn't she drive away at some point
in the middle of this whole process
which must have taken several seconds at
least to unfold
and and how did the lighter even stay
lit as it was thrown not to mention
where is that lighter now does she have
it it must have landed in the car right
and well look at the the picture of her
of her injuries
this is strange she says that her face
was on fire
is that what burn marks look like after
your face has been ignited
i don't know maybe it's never happened
to me admittedly but
it doesn't look exactly like what you
would expect
but then where are the witnesses to this
attack it happened in the middle of the
city a busy part of town
sure it was the middle of the night but
even so did no one else see this happen
did no one else have a
a run-in with this group of violent fire
wielding nazis
did they come out at a 1am with a
lighter fluid attack one person and
disappear forever
surely someone else saw them surely they
had a run-in with
someone else other than althea bernstein
and what about cameras
red light camera security cameras cell
phone cameras surely this was caught on
tape somewhere
and even if not surely these guys this
group are on video walking to the scene
or or leaving it it just seems like this
should be a very very easy case to crack
you should have
the fingerprints on the lighter that
must have landed in althea's car
you should have some kind of video you
should have some kind of witness
unless these were special ops clansmen
who rappelled down from a helicopter
then vanished into the night like highly
trained navy seals
there would be lots of evidence left
behind
and yet oddly enough we've heard nothing
about this case since it happened
no video has been released no witnesses
have come forward
no one so far as i know on social media
has said hey you know i saw these guys i
thought it was weird how they were
lugging lighter fluid around at 1am
nothing
well i shouldn't say nothing amanda
presta giacomo with the daily wire has
the update
such as it is quoting from a report in
the wisconsin state journal
which reached out to the madison police
last week and here's what spokesman joel
despain
said as an update this is the latest
we've gotten uh the
the update is there is nothing new to
release at this time
that's it that's all they said okay well
thanks joel but
how is there no new information it's
been seven weeks did you check the tapes
did you talk to witnesses
there's got to be some information there
right and if you check the tapes and
talk to people and witnesses and came up
with nothing
then that also is information really
important information
but you say nothing no information one
way or another you've been investigating
this for seven weeks and you know
absolutely nothing at all about it
really how
here's another weird thing about this
there was a confirmed arson attack that
same night
only it was carried out not by racist
and floral shirts
but by protesters at the city county
building which when you know it is only
about a mile from where althea says this
happened
is there a connection who knows but you
know you could see how a person involved
in an arson attack
might get burned and then how they might
not want to tell people that's how they
got burned
in fact the police released an image of
one of the people involved in the attack
on the building that night
um notice how they released the footage
or the
an image of this right away yet seven
weeks later and there's no image of
althea's attackers but anyway
look what he's using there it almost
looks like lighter fluid i don't know
look i'm just working through this it's
not like we're given anything to
go on here so i really don't know i'm
just sort of
trying to figure it out but it seems to
me this is where we're left and why the
madison police department is canceled
you know when it comes down to it either
racist psychopaths who tried to burn a
woman alive in the middle of the street
are still
out there in the community hunting for
their next victim and the madison police
department is doing nothing to stop them
and hasn't released any footage of them
or even a composite sketch or anything
else
and is thus putting lives in danger
through their inaction
or this is a hoax
a really deranged hoax and possibly a
hoax concocted to cover for another
crime
and the police department knows this or
strongly suspects it but isn't telling
us
and is covering for the hoaxer those
really seem to be the only plausible
scenarios
and i'd say that one is far more
plausible than the other so
either way whatever the truth is here
the madison police department is not
being honest
it's not being straightforward is trying
to cover something
is not doing their duty and thus is
canceled hate to do it
but they are they've left me no choice
uh and i still
for one would like to know the truth
about this case
i don't know about you but i would like
to know
one way or another we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there